[موسيقى]
فنادق في السعوديه مؤخرا باستبدال اللوحات
الخاصه بالفنانين التشكيليين في مرافق هذه
الفنادق بلوحات الفنانين تشكيليين سعوديين
قرار المهم ينعكس ايجابا على الطرفين
[موسيقى]
القرار يشملنا احمد السعوديين انه يكون
الاعمال انها بدات تطلع للنور فهي كانها
حادثه الادراج وحبيسه الغرف الان بدها
تطلع
هيخليهم تشجعوا اكثر انه مشاركوا في
المعارض اشتركوا في ايفنتها تشتركوا مع
فنادق وزي كده ويزودوا عدد اللوحات يزودوا
فعلا لانه الواحد كان يتصل انه في معرض
يلا ارسم لوحه لا دحين لا في مقتنيين
هيكون في حركه اكثر واسرع
الهويه التي نحكي عنها هي هويه عربيه ايضا
على سبيل المثال في لوحه مماثله احرف
عربيه وكلمات عربيه ماذا لو راها سائح
اجنبي كيف يقراها ولا اي درجه سيصبح
الفنان التشكيلي حريص على ان تصبح هذه
اللوحه اسهل قراءه بتكون في طبعا وسائل اه
وسيطه حتى يسهل عمليه المبتدا من ناحيه
مستويات مثلا لفل 1 لفل 2 حتى يتعرفوا
لانه هي تعتبر بالنسبه لهم اييييي معقده
شيء جديد عليهم
رمزيه في اللوحه فيها اسماء الله الحسنى
بالحروف العربيه بطريقه جداعيه وفي فكره
ان الكعبه في النص والمحرمين حوالينها بس
اليوم لو كانت لوحه زي هذه في المكان
السائحين او انت مو موجود عشان تترجم لهم
اللوحه في رايك يكفي وجود اللوحه او انك
راح تكون حديث انه اللوحه اللي تكون
موجوده تكون اسهل قراءتها فنيه او المترق
حيشوف في ابداعاته في افكار جديده وفي
خارجه عن الوف انه افكار ال- اعتياديه ما
في اقبال كثير فالافضل كل همم في له افكار
وحاجات ابداعيه اكثر تكون في تطور
في منتصف من ناحيه العمل من ناحيه
الجماليه والافكار او من ناحيه الرموز
[موسيقى]
بالتاكيد قرار ممثل سيكون له ابعاد اكثر
من كونها ابداعيه وفنيه سيحقق بكاتب
للفنانين التشكيليين فما هي اول شيء مكاسب
انه عامه الشعب يعرف ايش دور الفن
التشكيلي
يتوعها في اكثر من ناحيه الدراسه من ناحيه
علاج من ناحيه
توجه عن
الجوانب المتفرغ فيها ينشغل فيها بالفن
التشكيلي ويعرف انه هي مصدر رزق بعد الله
اول شيء غير كده انه ممكن يكون اسمي معروف
اكثر خارج يعني مو بس هنا في المملكه
العربيه همم كمان نطمح اننا نوصل للعالمين
[موسيقى]